[Musique]
tu étais tous bonsoir nouveau rendez
vous sur antenne 2 la trappe
qu'est ce que c'est la trappe c'est le
paradis et l'enfer la trappe c'est le
rêve et le rire le rire nous le verrons
dans quelques instants avec nos vedettes
stars invitées le rêve ce sont des
voyages que vous allez pouvoir gagner
grâce à un candidat que je présenterai
dans quelques instants
vous pourrez en effet en cinq semaines
faire le tour du monde et cette semaine
le premier candidat choisi de partir et
d'aller atterrir vendredi aux seychelles
peut-être avec vous ce que je vous
souhaite
il se peut qu'il pleuve chez vous qu'ils
fassent gris désormais chaque soir à
19h40 antenne 2 vous offre des vacances
le premier candidat s'appelle pierre de
l'applaudissant nous l'encourageons suis
je suis chirurgien dentiste dans la
banlieue parisienne vous êtes mariés
vous avez des enfants
je suis marié j'ai deux garçons deux
petits garçons et deux petits garçons
vous connaissez les seychelles ou pain
et non parce que j'aimerais bien les
connaître
alors pour simplifier les choses nous
avons décidé d'employer nouvelle unité
de mesure de distance le qui le rêve
sachez que les seychelles se trouve à 10
milles qui le rêve de paris vous devrez
répondre à des questions qui valent de
100 500 ou 1000 qui le rêve et nous
avons choisi pour vous aider deux stars
voici la première d'entre elles alice
sapritch bonsoir nice ap
à vos côtés pierre doris bonsoir dodo
vous allez sur d'éjectas histoire dira
un bond vous êtes sur des sièges un peu
particulier qui vont vous permettre si
pierre appuyé sur le bon bouton de
partir en enfer et de réaliser un gage
et pierre pour décoller pour quitter la
capitale pour inscrire votre compteur
les 200 premiers qui le rêve
vous allez décider d'envoyer alice ou
pierre à la trappe alors c'est un gage
qu'il nous est envoyé par madame favec
habite paris le voici
il faut que l'une des deux vedettes se
regardent dans une glace et rient mais
rit de bon coeur sans interruption
pendant 30 secondes qui voulez vous
envoyer à la trappe pour les 200
premiers qu'ils auraient le choix est
difficile mais je pense que je vais
envoyer à l'iss le diable est là le
diable est là les diablesses aussi et
vous allez à la trappe pour rire
face à ce miroir en 30 secondes alors
attendez attendez
devant ce miroir alice vous devrez
commencer par dire chéries-chéris votre
phrase célèbre nous sommes bien à coeur
et rire pendant 30 secondes sans
interruption pour que pierre gagne ses
200 premiers qui le rêve on y va top
chrono assez verte et 30 secondes au
pied rue
[Rires]
ayant gardé en affaires il faut quand
même se mettre à la place du miroir 20
et 30 secondes mais c'était bien merci à
l'iss le premier rendez vous le premier
jeu maintenant ok notre candidat devra
participer directement ces partis coque
en vrac question pour vous cher pierre
il se peut que pierre doris est alice
vous souffle par balles lundi en faveur
voici la question écoutez bien je suis
tout on le trouve au népal il mesure 1 m
il est très poilu non ils sifflent et
son odeur est très forte a fait pas moi
qui est il de 15 secondes
je pense tout de rouillac tête non ce
n'est pas le lien que non alors le yéti
c'est l'oeil et 10 200 kilomètres
supplémentaires bravo enfin il en faut
dix mille pour atteindre les seychelles
déjà votre compteur 702e question
regardez bien cette photo elle
représente le mont rushmore aux états
unis vous reconnaissez peut-être
certains des présidents des états unis
d'amérique
voilà vous devez maintenant me donner le
nom de trois présidents sur quatre
chronos 15 secondes et je pense qu'il y
à déjà abraham lincoln
c'est ça docteur ensuite en khl à
roosevelt
on ne peut rien vous cacher alors
j'hésite pour le dernier merci pierre
jefferson personnel il avait sculpté les
marx brothers alors souffler mais
discret maintenant quand même 900 kg
rêve là je veux l'aider
chez un ancien prothésiste dentaire et
de mon patron question laurence notre
test va vous faire découvrir un objet la
question est simple qu'est ce que c'est
pour 200 qu'il aurait possiblement
pierre donné la pierre vous c'est un
escroc notre écoute et vu la forme je
pense que c'est une ou un coco fesse
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas des seychelles
oui alex est d'avoir bonne réponse vous
en
d'accord comme perfect elle pousse dans
l'île de praslin dans l'archipel des
seychelles c'est le seul endroit a
besoin de pilule c'est le seul endroit
au monde à cette forme et il paraît que
le lait de cette mode coco a des vertus
aphrodisiaques léger récapitulatif 1100
qui le rêve mademoiselle sapritch on va
vous voir bientôt à la télévision jouer
dans un rôle très très très dur et très
sérieux c'est pourquoi je viens ce soir
m'amuser un petit peu avec vous et avec
mon candidat très sympathique bon il est
pas mal non tenu d'un veille très très
très bien s'il va tourner le chaperon
rouge voire tout à l'heure marie bové
vos voyages monsieur de reese ce passe
t'il bien mais je n'ai pas su retourner
les globes en dehors de ça je reviens
d'afrique mois d'affilée et métal mais
sans rature ma femme aux classes à paris
a été emporté par marois un orang outan
se disent l'a pris par la taille il a
emmené dans les sous bois
je me demande ce qu'il pouvait bien lui
trouver elle elle était heureuse au
départ et se croyait déjà hollywood dans
king kong disais tiens c'est dans la
pologne
et puis elle s'est prise la trouille
elle s'est mise à crier au secours
chéri un seul cours qu'est-ce que je
peux faire le dis comme d'habitude
divita la migraine
dès qu'il aura supplémentaire vite vite
vite
trois possibilités pour vous mon cher
pierre des questions à 200 j'ai l'air
d'un obsédé sexuel alors posé je sais
comment savez-vous saint lys où nous
avons passé un très bon moment ensemble
il ya quelques années de la société
j'attaque le cher quand même à trois
possibilités pour vous pierre le
candidat une question ou plusieurs
questions à 200 500 et 1000 qui le rêve
mais attention lorsque le gong retentit
rhin pierre doris partira à la trappe
pour l'équivalent de la question nous
sommes bien d'accord et donc essayer de
bien jouer c'est en fonction du temps
qui nous reste que je ne connais pas et
que vous ne connaissez pas première
question à combien
deux cents 200 kg rêve la voici c'est
une question à laquelle vous allez
pouvoir répondre
vous avez sans doute lu entendu ou vu le
fait divers cet été dans la presse à la
radio ou à la télévision
quatre soldats soviétiques qui avait
envie de bouteilles de vodka en échanger
ou deux caisses de vodka longs échangés
contre quelque chose quoi à votre avis
leurs gamelles remplies de caviar leurs
chars d'assaut ou un mois de soldes côté
là je pense que c'est le char d'assaut
c'est le char d'assaut
ces soldats soviétiques qui manquait
d'alcool ont donné leur char d'assaut un
cafetier contre deux caisses de vodka
bon c'est un bon moyen pour avoir
l'armée russe deuxième question de
donner sans voix de tous les cas des
canaux deuxième question 200 500 milles
je vais essayer 500 500 d'accord dans
voici
d'après les recherches faites à munich
20 minutes d'amour demande autant de
calories qu'un hamburger cud pizza aux
champignons ou qu'une demi tablettes de
chocolat à notre avis c'est très
difficile ça intéresse alice une
impression 20 minutes d'amour quand je
suis assez gourmands le chocolat pardon
internet alice mais pardon moi je dirais
pilsen pizza au chocolat je ne sais pas
alors 20 minutes d'amour représentent
autant de calories qu'un hamburger
chocolat le chocolat c'est alice la
spécialiste qui avait raison c'était
une autre question mine 1000 points 1000
milles au même utile aux mines qui le
rêve
8 il aurait il fallait aux seychelles
alors voici la question à 1000 qui le
rêve christophe colomb avait baptisé
cuba margherita juana ou teresa chrono
pour 15 secondes christophe que l'on
avait baptisé cuba margherita cruanas ou
teresa
je ne sais pas du tout j'ai dit rose art
teresa vous dites teresa hélas non
chocolat c'est erwan à vous ne le saviez
pas vous resterez vous restez à 13 100
kg rêve est ce que nous avons le temps
de poser une question supplémentaire non
me dit on alors ne nous imposons pas par
conséquent maintenant vous devez
impérativement envoyer pierre doris à la
trappe pour les 1000 kg rêve qui
viennent de vous faire défaut
attention on appuie sur un bouton
laissez-vous ce lien
laissez-nous faire esseulé vite près de
ce téléphone c'est un gage qui nous
vient de lyon bien passé je vous en prie
tablier de cent vingt six ans par madame
perrin qui est lyonnaise et qui vous
annonce une très très mauvaise nouvelle
on cherche pire loris me alice sapritch
vient de rompre avec vous parfaite et si
et vous aurez une minute pour l'appeler
au téléphone et tenter de la reconquérir
mais ça n'est pas tout en plus vous
devrez essayer de lui faire prononcer un
mot ce mot va apparaître sur l'écran
pour nos téléspectateurs et uniquement
ce mot le voici
regardez bien bien parfait une minute
donc pour reconquérir alice sapritch
vous décrocher le téléphone et en
principe il est au bout du fil
en principe si vous savez elle est très
demandée un été calme à quitte alors l
agglo chiffres son numéro c'est une
originale à l'eau à nice à louis des
patates des centrales à tétouan à quoi
je vais te donner un conseil qu'il a
omis trop sa tête je vais trouver des
satisfactions commencer
continuez toujours comme s'il nous est
rappelé la vie et 10 40 secondes à nos
avis d'appel y avait tant de seconde
tu te souviens de tout ce que j'ai fait
pour toi tu te rappelles de revient je
t'ai refaire des manteaux somptueux
quand tu avais la bronchite stauffer
petites choses à encourir je ne pense
que c'était un c'est en quoi ce truc à
te quitte parce que tu me dégoûtes te
dégoûte
le sata dégoûte pourquoi parce que le
tueur jetant mené à la pêche aux requins
ça lui a emmené à la prison rocard
d'accord et parce que tu étais en colère
parce que chez vous ductus yard amorce
alors c'est normal trop gros appelez
plus et quand on s'était dit que tu
pouvais ilité superbad et que tu testé
par la fête du mans n'a voulu un pays si
la bce dit mais je t'aime où es tu as
été une façon bizarre d'aimer les gens
je t'adore à 10,50 lors si malheureux
vous l'avez mesdames messieurs constaté
com - pierre doris est parfaitement
parler aux femmes avec les mots qu'il
faut mais malheureusement le mot que
nous attendions le mot lapin n'a pas été
prononcée alors ce qui donne au niveau
des kills au rêve qui donne pas grand
chose est-ce qu'on peut le voir sachant
pierre 1300 kg rêve 1300 il faut il en
faut dix mille pour atteindre les
seychelles d'ici à vendredi
en principe ça devrait bien se passer de
toute façon notre notre candidat est
vous qui avait envoyé des cartes
postales aurait des récompenses à ce
propos si vous voulez participer à la
trappe en tant que candidat autant que
en tant qu'auteur de gaz où vous serez
récompensé bien entendu ou tout
simplement en envoyer une carte postale
pour partir en voyage et pour partir en
vacances à antenne 2 vous écrivez à
l'adresse suivante la trappe bon sens la
star cedex 1 835 75 608 paris brune ou
pourris me l'a donné sa liste
notre info la trappe à bien ces decks
835 835 75,6 108,75 608 paris blonde
c'est vrai bien à bientôt à demain matin
à demain matin bien sûr pour l'académie
de 9 à 12h vite sur antenne 2 et à
demain soir avec pierre doris et alice
sapritch pour la tap
bonsoir
[Musique]
il
bonsoir deuxième rendez-vous de la
trappe bienvenue sur ce plateau
bienvenue au paradis bienvenue en enfer
il faut en parler vendredi
nous tirerons une carte postale et vous
partirez peut-être grâce aux antennes de
aux seychelles
grâce aux cadeaux que nous offrons grâce
au tour du monde que notre candidat va
peut-être réalisé faut dire que les
seychelles se trouve à 10 milles qui le
rêve de paris la logique voudrait que
notre candidat ait fait hier 2500 kg
rêve pour que tout aille bien ce n'est
pas le cas et là à se regarder il en est
à 13 cents qui le rêve donc notre
candidat a un petit peu de retard c'est
pourquoi je vous demande où dès
maintenant de l'encourager bonsoir
pierre est trop dure peut-être faire
confiance davantage confiance aux
vedettes qui sont à alice sapritch
bonsoir et l'homme qui sait trouver les
mots pour parler aux femmes qui allaient
déjà 500 kg rêve en choisissant
d'envoyer est l'une des deux vedettes à
la trappe
c'est un gage qui a été envoyé et qui
nous vient des gueux morte monsieur sam
vesty qu'il faut remplacer alain
gillot-pétré et donner la météo nous
donner le temps de demain alors à votre
avis qui pourrait faire ça d'une façon
tout à fait remarquable alice sapritch
ou pierre doris de boutons sont là vous
en voyez qui vous voulez un attrape je
pense que pierre doris pas très bien
[Applaudissements]
jean-pierre quel sale temps mon cher
pierre ochs quel sale temps quel va être
le temps de demain c'est le premier gage
de ce soir vous allez nous le dire en
vous plaçant donc devant cette carte et
vous avez disposer de plusieurs symboles
que voici la neige le soleil et les
nuages la pluie en une minute vous
devrez disposer si symbole sur la carte
mais sachez que il y en a quelques-uns
qui sont démagnétisée non il m'a donc
faire le que falloir faire le
commentaire d'un à gillot pétré nous
sommes bien d'accord et disposer si
symbole sur la carte le chrono par ces
partis le temps de demain par pierre de
risques avant toute chose je tiens à
vous dire mesdames et messieurs quand un
grand cyclone ne nous arrive des açores
il va se perdre dans la chambre des
députés fêtera battre un horrible on
trouvera la droite à la place de la
gauche lors elle c'est merveilleux voilà
je prépare conditions du vully
formidable je suis paumé tradinaires
voilà j'aurai atteint la limite on
change nous les gens du nord
en acquittant de saclay rien tout allait
voilà dans la neige un peu de neige
surtout ses patins là un scandale vous
prenez d'avoir toujours la flotte
voilà des cours d'eau et salue d'une
heure pour deux regarde et le soleil la
chaleur
arrivé non je n'ai pas dit s'il
s'appelle le cyclone alice jamais bien
et téléspectateurs le cyclone alice
s'annonce vous entendez chéries chéris
êtes prévenus voilà mais regardez ma
prochaine du risque indique beaucoup de
choses
voilà ça c'était pour la danse et
cyclones ça c'est pour la danse et le
ciel bleu fait d'accord merci beaucoup
monsieur à nos silos de risque oui on
s'arrête on s'arrête parce que croque en
vrac c'est le projet va payer pour la
fraternité bon ça va on laisserait
terminer comme ça va nous gêner trois
scènes le contrat décroché par
l'assassin temps variable voyez ça s'est
un temps 11 des voix s'y attendait pas
du tout le monde reste ce soir
voilà qui leur est complémentaire de
risque à la question de 100 kg rêve pour
vous il me déranger si les canadiens qui
regarde bien souvent antenne 2 offre de
la fesse acceptez-vous sans hésiter
question qu'est ce que la fesse
c'est à vous bien partenaires oui je
regardais moi je pense que ça doit être
quelque chose de comestible
oui et c'est bien quoi donc je ne sais
pas un gâteau nous conte une pâtisserie
josé nord oui je pense qu'on va accepter
votre réponse en est assez comestibles
c'est du jambon bonne réponse de notre
[Musique]
photo maintenant ceux effectivement
différents oeuvres authentiques
ce bâtiment est un homme aéroports dans
quelle ville d'australie est il si tu es
ce bâtiment est un opéra dans quelle
ville d'australie est il si tu es là je
pense que c'est à sydney très bonne
réponse de faure va bien vous êtes vous
avancez 1
vous êtes passionné de voyages non oui
j'aimerais bien oui ou non mais je vous
en avais déjà réalisés n'ont pas
beaucoup ont pourtant pas beaucoup vous
préférez les canines des incisives et
les molaires pour le moment mais enfin
ça ne durera peut-être pas triste état
autre question maintenant oui c'est un
film célèbre de denys de la patellière
sur des dialogues de michel audiard se
dérouler dans le désert libyen pendant
la seconde guerre quel est le titre du
film là je pense que ça ne sera pas de
difficulté non plus non c'est pas taxi
photographe oui un taxi pour tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va beaucoup mieux en fait vous avez
atteint le score du premier jour 1 2400
qui défendait ce temps donc vous avez
maintenant jusqu'à la fin d'émission
pour faire votre score d'aujourd'hui
mardi à nice va bien on vous a pas
entendu aller ce qu'est ce qui se passe
j'écoute je regarde beaucoup je peux
vous faire une confidence en vous disant
que hier soir alice sapritch médias la
fin il est pas mal notre candidat je
sais pas ce que ça signifie je ne sais
pas vous non j'attendais ça remercierai
pierre doris vous allez tourner
qu'est-ce que je dois bien ne rien du
tout
marthe mercadier parlé m'ont un peu je
parle maintenant cadier dans une pièce à
la rentrée la renaissance les voisins du
dessous du juge c'est un vieux collage
vous savez mark et moi on a joué trois
pièces je regrette si je te trompes ou
analyse javeed mais tu sais que tu
viendras j'ai toujours un succès fou
auprès des femmes ça sans me vanter lire
encore une femme a tapé pendant quatre
heures à la porte de ma chambre et je ne
vais pas laisser sortie reste à mon âge
je suis toujours les femmes dans les
rues mais je ne sais plus pourquoi durée
se tiens à vous rassurer halliche défilé
merveilleux de dos de dos on y donnait
20 ans hop
mais vous les reprenez de face
[Applaudissements]
les défunts payante
j'ai maintenant pour vous des questions
à 200 500 et 1000 qui le rêve que faites
vous quand je vais tenter la question à
1000 carrément la question à 1000 kg
attentionné un petit peu qu'appelle-t-on
en inde
lapouge ap eu j a trois possibilités la
lutte nationale un plat à base de
haricots ou une offrande religieuse pour
1000 kg rêves coûtait je crois avoir lu
ça quelque part je pense que c'est une
fronde religieux c'est une très bonne
réponse demain
j'aime beaucoup quand on me dit ça je
crois avoir lu ça quelque part vraiment
vous vous intéressez aux voyages vous
lisez où j'ai d'ailleurs avant cette
émission j'ai quand même quelque peu
revu certaines choses bon vous avez
révisé un petit parce que si vous
conseiller sur alice avril chez pure
boys
vous avez bien avoir quelque chose il
reste des questions à 200 et 1 500
killer instinct sans ça sans hockey
jadis le roi une joya inventa un truc
génial c'est au cameroun le fil à couper
le beurre la fermeture à glissière ou le
moulin à café elektric cameroun jadis
lors enjoy a inventé un truc génial
s'agissait-il du fil à couper le beurre
de fermeture à glissière ou d'un moulin
à café elektric je pense que le il ya du
café au cameroun où je dois être le
moulin à café
pierre doris est l fil à couper le
beurre et vous aller sans l'autre
c'est à dire la fermeture éclair la
fermeture éclair
eh bien je me demande parfois pourquoi
vous êtes venu c'est pire qu'un
restaurant
vous êtes là heureusement tu poses éclat
parce que vous allez bientôt passer à la
trappe très bonnes réponses 3900 km que
faites vous encore une question oui
cinq cent 500 c'est bien joué kumar à la
dan est devenu un héros du sri lanka en
1979 pour avoir durant 180 7 heures et
28 minutes et sans interruption fait du
vélo embrassé sa compagne prier en
restant sur une jambe
kumar à nantes d'un est devenu un héros
du sri-lanka pour avoir durant 180 7
heures et des poussières fait du vélo
embrassé sa compagne ou prier sur une
jambe
j'aurais dit prier sur une jambe vous
devriez sur une vous êtes d'accord piano
oui vous êtes tous d'accord mais tous
les trois tort comme ça y'a pas de
problème
merci c'était il a fait du vélo pendant
180 7 heures et 28 minutes on avait
comme nom
vous mélangez les questionnaires
le gant vient de retentir
vous jouiez pour 500 kg rêve que vous
n'avez pas gagné par conséquent vous
allez envoyer maintenant mademoiselle
alice a pris à la trappe
nous sommes bien d'accord pour
l'équivalent mais cet avis vous allez
comprendre tout de suite c'est un gage
qui nous a été envoyé par monsieur rodo
qui habite marseille dans les bouches du
rhône ce tablier vous va très très bien
voici trois paquets de lessive identique
venait derrière ces barils de lessive
cette lessive s'appelle la lessive
l'afld trappe à vous devez pendant 30
secondes me vanter les qualités de cette
lessive nous sommes bien d'accord
vous allez donc faire de la publicité
pour la lessive la frappe ensuite je
vous demanderais autre chose ma chère à
l'iss
je vous en prie prenez un baril dans vos
bras il a beaucoup de chance baril et
vente et nous les qualités de cette
étude c'est parti en seconde à la trappe
l'aller 6 mondial c'est bouillir le
linge même au pôle nord l afte où les
slips et chenilles
[Musique]
les caleçons le vatican l'adopter pour
laver les consciences fr a dépassé la
réclame qu'est-ce qui se passe il se
passe que les 30 secondes sont écoulés
avant mais c'est pas mal c'est bien ça
c'était la première à 6500 qu'il aurait
pu remarquer vous devez choisir l'un des
trois barils un seul qu'on tient
véritablement de la lessive et vous
devez la nationale 6 et de la lessive
c'est bon si ce n'est pas de la lessive
s'est perdu à l'itie alesi qui fait
souvent votre plaisir
prenez n'importe quelle conne et celui
ci vous l'ouvrez et enfin vous faites
bien votre ici les stylos cello oui aux
énormes à la hausse et le manger pour
tout achat
les civils à ne pas marquer les 500 kg
c'est bien je demande à pierre doris de
venir nos jeunes quand même si coupé oui
alors voilà notre candidat est ce cas là
que nous allons revoir à marquer un
certain nombre de kilos rêve
vous allez les voir tout de suite mon
cher pierre vous reviendrez quand même
demain on met bien sûr bien sûr pour
essayer d'atteindre les seychelles
vous avez ici à 1900 qui le rêve vous
avez un petit peu de retard mais ne vous
inquiétez pas rien n'est perdu
je vous remercie d'être resté avec nous
ce soir encore si vous voulez gagner si
vous voulez jouer si vous voulez envoyer
dégage une seule adresse la voici la
trappe cedex 1 835 75 608 paris brune
bonsoir à damas pour l'académie des neuf
et adama sall
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]